- You should snap this.
- [Keith] Oh yeah!
(techno music)
- Looks good.
- I'm gonna tag that in San Francisco.
- No, no, no.
Don't tag Dolores Park.
Jeff lives like, two blocks from here.
- Oh my God, Keith!
Mocha butter cream!
- Oh, we shouldn't.
- We're on vacation.
We're on vacation.
- What if Jeff just runs into us,
and he's like, "You guys are here?"
- I don't know, we haven't talked to him
since we sabotaged his birthday.
I get it, you're trying
to gentrify this place,
but like, where's the Starbucks?
This coffee is like, so
much better than our coffee.
God, the women are even prettier here too.
When you're people like us,
a Margarita's a whole meal.
There's something so attractive about a
- [Both] Woman with a kid.
- Right?
I thought I was crazy.
- No.
- It's crazy tonight, though.
I've got two bottles of wine for the room.
This is so embarrassing, uh,
do you have a wine key?
We have reservations for Margaritas.
- Alright, I just wanna
lay out for a little bit.
- Thank you.
Sorry, sorry.
Okay, sorry.
- Apologize more.
To the best trip ever!
It's like the best trip ever.
This is the best vacation ever.
- Right?
Sorry.
- I thought we were going to a spa.
- We are.
Derek said the best spa is in Chinatown,
it has a purple sign.
- Keith, emojis!
- [Keith] Oh my gosh, you are so cute.
How are you still single?
- You are the nicest to me.
- I've never had fun like this before.
I brought a lot of different
swimsuit options too.
I feel like they're all too slutty.
Do I go cute or hot?
♫ All I ever wanted-- ♫
Oh, that's good.
Tag me in that.
- Sure.
♫ Vacation how to get away ♫
- Is it "Time to get away"
or "How to get away"?
- I thought it was "Have to get away."
- "Have to get away"?
That's what vacations are for,
they're about, like,
getting to know each other
at a different level.
You deserve this vacation.
- You deserve to be treated like a prince.
- Okay, you're right.
It's been crazy lately.
- I don't even want to vacation
with my family ever again.
You think we'll ever use the other bed?
- Hi, this is stupid, I'm sorry, is it
♫ Vacation all I ever wanted
♫ Vacation, time to get away ♫
Or is it "Have to get away"?
or is it "How to get away"?
This is stupid, I'm sorry.